the average male drinks two liters of
water when active outdoors with the
standard deviation of 0.7 liters you are
planning a full-day nature trip for 50
men 50 men and will bring 110 liters of
water what is the probability that you
will run out of water so let's think
about what's happening here so there's
some distribution of how much how many
litres the average man needs when
they're active outdoors and let me just
draw an example it might look something
like this so this is so they're all
going to need at least more than zero
liters so this would be zero liters over
here the average male so the mean of the
amount of water a man needs when active
outdoors is two liters so two liters
would be right over here so the mean is
equal to two liters it has a standard
deviation of 0.7 liters or 0.7 liters so
the standard deviation maybe I'll draw
it this way so this distribution once
again we don't know whether it's a
normal distribution or not it could just
be some type of crazy distribution so so
maybe you know some people need almost
close to well everyone needs a little
bit of water but maybe some people need
very very little water then you have a
lot of people who need that maybe some
people who need more and maybe you know
no one can drink more than maybe this is
like four liters of water so maybe this
is the actual distribution and then one
standard deviation in is going to be 0.7
liters away so this is 1.7 liters is so
this would be one liter
two liters three liters so one standard
deviation is going to be about that far
away from the mean if you go above it
it'll be about that far if you go below
it let me draw this is the standard
deviation that right there is the
standard deviation to the right that's
the standard deviation to the left and
we know that the standard deviation is
equal to I'll write the zero in front
0.7 liters so that's the actual
distribution of how much water the
average man needs when active now what's
interesting about this problem we are
planning a full-day nature trip for 50
men and we'll bring a hundred and ten
liters of water what is the probability
that you will run
out so the probability that you will run
out let me let me write this down the
probability that I will or that you will
run out run out is equal or is the same
thing as the probability the probability
that we use more than 110 liters use
more than 110 liters on our outdoor
nature day whatever we're doing which is
the same thing as the probability if we
use more than 110 liters that means that
on average because we have 50 minutes so
110 divided by 50 is what that's two
points let me get the calculator out
just so we don't make any so we don't
make any mistakes here so this is going
to be the calculator out so on average
if we have 110 liter 110 liters it's
going to be drunk by 50 men including
ourselves I guess that means that it's
the problem so that we would run out if
on average more than 2.2 liters is used
per man so this is the same thing as the
probability of the average or maybe we
should say the sample mean or let me
write it this way that the average the
average water use water use per man of
our 50 men is greater than or we could
say greater than or equal to greater let
me say greater than well I'll say
greater than because if we write on the
money then we won't run out of water is
greater than 2.2 2.2 liters per man so
let's think about this we are
essentially taking 50 men out of a
universal sample and we got this data
who knows where we got this data from
that the average man drinks 2 liters and
that the standard deviation is this
maybe some there's some huge study and
this was the best estimate of what the
population parameters are that this is
the mean and this is a standard
deviation now we're sampling 50 men and
what we need to do is figure out
essentially what is the probability that
the mean of this sample that the sample
mean is going to be greater than 2.2
liters and to
do that we have to figure out the
distribution of the sampling mean and we
know what that's called if the sampling
distribution of the sample means and we
know that that is going to net be a
normal distribution we know a few of the
properties of that normal distribution
so this is the distribution of just all
men and then if you take samples of say
50 men so this will be let me write this
down so down here I'm going to draw I'm
going to draw the sampling distribution
the sampling distribution distribution
of the sample mean of the sample mean
when when n so when our sample size is
equal to 50 when our sample size is 50
so this is essentially telling us the
likelihood of the different means when
we are sampling 50 men from this
population and taking their average
water use so let me draw that so let's
say this is frequency and then here are
the different values now the mean value
of this the mean the mean let me write
the mean of the sampling distribution of
the sample mean this x-bar that's really
just the sample mean right over there is
equal to it's going to be equal to if we
were to if we were to do this millions
and millions of times if we were to plot
all of them the means when we keep
taking samples of 50 and there were plot
them all out we would show that though
this this mean of distribution is
actually going to be the mean of our
actual population so it's going to be
the same value I want to do in that same
blue it's going to be the same value as
this population over here so that is
going to be two liters so we still have
we're still centered at two liters but
what's neat about this is that the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
so you take 50 people find their mean
plot the frequency 50 people find the
mean this is actually going to be a
normal distribution regardless of you
know this one just has a well-defined
standard deviation I mean it's not
normal even though this one isn't normal
this one over here will be and we've
seen it in multiple videos already so
this is going to be a normal
distribution and the standard deviation
and we saw this in the last video and we
hopefully we've got a little bit of
intuition for why this is true the
standard DV
station actually put a better way the
variance the variance of the sample mean
is going to be the variance so remember
it's going to be this is standard
deviation so it's going to be the
variance of the population divided by N
and if you wanted the standard deviation
of this distribution right here you just
take the square root of both sides so if
you take the square root of both sides
of that we have the standard deviation
of the sample mean is going to be equal
to the square root of this side over
here is going to be equal to the
standard deviation of the population
divided by the square root of N and
what's this going to be in our case we
know what the standard deviation of the
population is it is 0.7 0.7 0.7 and what
is n we have 50 men so 0.7 over the
square root of 50 now let's figure out
what that is with the calculator so we
have we have 0.7 divided by the square
root of 50 and we have 0.09 well I'll
say 0.098 was pretty close to 0.99 so
I'll just write that down so it's this
is equal to 0.09 9 that's going to be
the standard deviation of this so it's
going to have a lower standard deviation
so it's going to look the distribution
it's going to be normal it's going to
look something like this
so this is this is three liters over
here this is one liter one liter the
standard deviation is almost a tenth so
it's going to be a much narrower much
narrower distribution it's going to look
something I'm drum I try my best to draw
it it's going to look something like
something like this something like this
you get the idea where the standard
deviation right now is almost point one
so it's point zero nine almost a tenth
so it's going to be you know something
one standard deviation away is going to
look something like that so we have our
distribution it's a normal distribution
and now let's go back to our question
that we're asking we want to know the
probability that our say
simple we'll have an average that our
sample will have an average greater than
2.2 so this is this is the distribution
of all of the possible samples the means
of all of the possible samples now to be
greater than two point two two point two
is going to be right around here two
point two is going to be right around
here so we want to essentially are
asking we will run out if our sample
mean falls into this bucket over here so
we essentially need to figure out what
is you can even view it as what's this
area under this curve there and to
figure that out we just have to figure
out how many standard deviations above
the mean we are which is going to be our
z-score and then we could use a Z table
to figure out what this area right over
here is so if we are so we want to know
when we are above 2.2 liters so 2.2
liters 2.2 we could even do it in our
head 2.2 liters is what we care about
that's right over here
that is our mean is 2 so we are point
two above the mean above the mean above
the mean and if we want that in terms of
in terms of standard deviations we just
divide this by the standard deviation of
this distribution over here and we
figured out what that is the standard
deviation of this distribution is 0.09 9
so if we take and you'll see a formula
where you take this value minus the mean
and divide it by the standard deviation
that's all we're doing we're just figure
out how much how many standard
deviations above the mean we are so you
just take this number right over here
divided by the standard deviation so
zero point zero nine nine or zero point
zero nine nine and then we get let's get
our calculator and actually had the
exact number over here so we can just
take point two we could just take this
point two point two divided by this
value over here and on this calculator
when I press second answer just means
the last answer so I'm taking point two
divided by this value over there and I
get two point zero two zero so this
means so that means that this value or
actually right this probability is the
same probability
is the same probability of being 2.0 two
standard deviations standard deviations
oh maybe I should write it this way more
than more than let me write it down here
where I have more space so this is this
all boils down to the probability of
running out of water is the probability
that the sample mean will be more than
just the 50 that we happen to select
remember if we take a bunch of samples
of 50 and plot all of them we'll get
this whole distribution for the 150 the
group of 50 that we happen to select the
probability of running out of water is
the same thing as the probability of the
mean of those people will be more than
two point zero two zero standard
deviations standard deviations above the
mean above the mean of this distribution
which they're actually the same the same
the same distribution so what is that
going to be and here we just have to
look up our Z table remember this two
point zero two is just this value right
here 0.2 divided by zero point zero nine
I just have to pause the video because
there's some type of fighter jet outside
or something anyway hopefully they won't
they won't come back but anyway so we
need to figure out the probability that
the sample mean will be more than two
point zero two standard deviations above
the mean and to figure that out we go to
a Z table and you can find this pretty
much anywhere usually it's in any stat
book or on the internet wherever and so
essentially we want to know the
probability the Z table will tell you
how much area is below this value so if
you go to Z of two point zero two that
was the value that we were dealing with
right you have two point zero two it was
so you go for the first digit we go to
two point zero and it was two point zero
two point zero two two point zero two is
right over there right so we had two
point zero and then the next digit you
go up here so it's two point zero two is
right over there so this point nine
seven eight three let me write it down
over here this point nine seven eight
three I want to be very careful zero
point nine seven eight
that Z table did not that's not this
value
here this point nine seven eight three
on the z table that is giving us this
whole area over here it's giving us the
probability that we are below that value
that we are less than we are less than
2.0 two standard deviations above the
mean so it's giving us that value over
here so to answer our question to answer
this probability we just have to
subtract this from one because these
will all add up to one so we just take
our calculator back out and we just take
one minus one minus 0.9 seven eight
three is equal to point zero two one
seven so this right here is point zero
two one seven or another way you could
say it it is a two point one seven
percent probability that we will run out
of water and we are done let me sure I
got make sure I got that number right so
that number it was Y at point two zero
one seven right so it's a two point one
seven percent chance we run out of water